the king's man takes the kingsman series
back to where it all started with the
backdrop of world war one and it might
be setting up a confrontation with the
biggest villain of world war ii i'm
gonna love calling you
[Music]
the king's man centers on orlando duke
of oxford the originator of the kingsman
organization played by rafe fines we
follow orlando and his son conrad as
they become entangled in world war one
and the conspiracies behind it leading
up to the creation of the kingsman
organization world war one is a film's
backdrop but it also factors into the
narrative in several major ways the
events setting the war in motion are
being masterminded by the elusive and
villainous shepherd and the war also
helps to find the relationship between
orlando and his son protege conrad
conrad wants to fight alongside his
fellow countrymen something his father
objects to his reluctance stems from
orlando's wife dying in front of him
years prior when his son conrad was only
a young boy despite his objections and
even recruiting comrade to join his
proto-kingsman organization his son
disobeys his orders and runs off to
enlist
real power
is not found running off to war comrade
is almost pulled from active duty in a
final attempt by orlando to save him but
to no avail comrade switches places with
another soldier played by aaron taylor
johnson and distressed into the heart of
battle in a spectacular sequence comrade
makes his way across the infamous no
man's land to save a soldier's life the
soldier in question is a recipient of
vital information that in the right
hands could help end the war despite
risking life and limb to save the man's
life comrade's false identity is
discovered by another trigger-happy
soldier before he can explain his
situation he's marked as a potential spy
and shot to death
losing his only son sends orlando into a
deep depression no longer motivated to
save the world he sits alone in his
study unshaven and drinking himself into
a stupor until polly gives him a pep
talk that pulls him out of his miserable
state he marks this renewed vigor by
requesting a cup of tea and having a
shave the timing couldn't be any better
as the united states president is
ignoring advice to join the war this is
shown to be yet another sinister
machination of the mysterious shepherd
and his crony mata hari through hari's
infamous seductions they have acquired
footage of the president engaging in
very lewd blackmail worthy activities
all in an effort to have him removed and
replaced with a new president under the
shepherd's controller orlando is quick
to uncover this sinister plan and
manages to defeat hari in hand-to-hand
combat recognizing her scarf orlando was
quick to note that his fabric only comes
from a specific kind of goat a final
revelation that allows orlando and his
allies to figure out the shepherd's
location and put their plan in motion
with the shepherd's end game quickly
approaching orlando and his team have to
enact their plan right away that plan
hinges on a then new invention the
parachute which will allow them to swoop
down on enemy territory from above after
some comical deliberations as to who
will actually jump out of the plane
orlando opts to do it himself in a tense
sequence reminiscent of roxy's
suspenseful descent from the first film
orlando nearly meets his end during his
airborne entrance however thanks to
knives placed in his shoes he's able to
scale the cliff leading to the
shepherd's lair polly and schuler
quickly make their presence known as
well by taking out various guards
through gunfire and close quarter combat
orlando himself has to contend with the
shepherd's largest guard reminiscent of
bond villains like jaws in a fistfight
chola makes his way up to the lair and
is able to help orlando subdue the
unruly behemoth it's here that they
finally venture inside the lair to
confront the shepherd face to face
orlando and scholar make their way into
the shepherd's lair where they finally
see his face orlando is shocked to see
that the shepherd is none other than
captain martin it would have been
masquerading as herbert kitchener's
right-hand man this reveal explains how
the shepherd was often two steps ahead
of the heroes and privy to certain top
secret information his motivations are
kept fairly vague however only including
a brief backstory about his family's
mill being closed as a child
after some banter orlando and morton
agreed to a sword duel which leads to
the first utterance of mana's maketh man
a fixture phrase of the original
kingsman film manners
maker
man the two match each other in terms of
skill and combat prowess until morton
tries to use his swords hidden gun
scholar ever the dependable friend takes
a bullet to his shoulder for orlando
allowing him to continue the fight the
battle reaches the cliff's edge of the
lair where it appears morton has gotten
the upper hand on orlando until one of
morton's own goats one had been
particularly cruel to skewers him with
its horn initially orlando attempts the
honorable path and refuses to let him
drop but ultimately decides to let
morton fall to his doom it's a cathartic
moment orlando has saved the day not to
mention the world and has become the man
that conrad would have been
with the shepherd dispatched and the
evidence of blackmail against the
president disposed of the united states
officially joins the war the film cuts
ahead to the conclusion of world war one
and we see england's exuberant post-war
celebrations good has triumphed and
while his efforts will go unknown by the
world orlando is content having lived up
to comrade's hopes for him but while
this mission is over it appears there is
still work to be done for orlando and
his compatriots in the final moments of
the king's man orlando gathers his
allies polly scholar and the soldier who
switched places with conrad he proceeds
to sit them all down and give them new
code names each based on the legend of
king arthur he gives them the rundown as
to what their job is and how they will
be operating officially forming the
kingsman organization kingsman is it
and lady after the credits we see that
even in death the shepherd had one final
trick up his sleeve we are showing erik
yan hanusin conducting some business at
an unknown subterranean lair he
introduces his associate to a new player
in their sinister machinations a young
man by the name of adolf hitler
showing that just as the kingsmen are
evolving so are their enemies
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one